they call it the devil's drug
i want to stop using heroin
you know
because it's wrecked my life
it grips and kills the most vulnerable
people living the most desperate of
lives
you know people dying from something
you've given them does murder
right now many addicts don't know if the
next hit will be their last
people love these people
somebody's parents someone's sons
daughters aunties uncles and
children
[Music]
bev has battled her own addiction to
heroin
she's lost friends before
but never so many in such a short space
of time
are your friends scared about the stuff
that's going around i think they're just
hoping it's not going to happen to them
but they're seeing people dying around
them
definitely i've i've seen somebody die
in front of me in a hostel
um in the corridor
and they done hit walked out the door
and dropped down
because of heroin yeah
how did that make you
feel
so
it still lets me just say it's people
you spend time with
i don't think you ever
get over it
literally
actually watching someone take their
life breath and
[Music]
not being able to talk to him again not
saying sorry because i have an argument
not
knowing like
you know if you knew that was the last
time you were going to speak to them
you'd behave different
we've spoken to heroin users government
advisors and charities and they all say
more people are dying from heroin
than ever before
that's because a vulnerable community is
now receiving less support
and taking more dangerous drugs
this is 20 pounds
that's pure crack cocaine yeah
and there's no way of you knowing what
that heroine has been mixed with no
and until you've taken it you still
wouldn't know what's in there
no of course not how would you know bev
no longer uses heroin but her friends do
and these are their drugs
they use this flat as a safe space to
get high
synthetic opioids like fentanyl are
being used to bulk out the drugs it
increases profits and gives users a
greater high
this is a 10 pound it also makes this
extremely addictive and most dangerous
drug
even more deadly
no one's listening to the fact they're
using heroin first so then
people are dying
let me ask you then why should they care
that people are taken away because
people are dying
because dealers are mixing up with god
knows what chemical they can come up
with because at a weight so they can get
a profit so you're paying to kill
someone
it's murder
you know people are dying from something
you've given them does murder
how many people have you seen die
through bad heroin in the last few
months how many friends have you lost i
can't say more than 10.
jungle
is seeing it too
he says since november he's been losing
friends to overdoses
every week
that's why he's got a prescription for
methadone
he's trying to get clean you go to the
doctor's surgery you get my urine test
that determined the amount of heroin in
your body so they know what dorsey is
just start here how long have you been
on this um well
since christmas you know because he's my
friend yeah since my two friends died
yeah
i want to stop using heroin especially
you know
because it's written my life
i've got three beautiful kidada success
in my motto 14 years i'm a qualified
sous chef i got so much to my dad was a
medical doctor you understand
and like look at me i can't even find 50
p to but i cannot call some time
yeah
i'm i'm just existing because of heroin
buckingham palace
five minutes away
10 downing street seven minutes away
yeah
you know
westminster's train station i got four
friends
sleeping one of them died last year
aaron overdose
yeah what i'm trying to say close to the
house of parliament right under their
nose and my friends see that five months
this is not just a problem for those
living in the margins of society
while filming this report sky news
witnessed what appeared to be an
exchange of drugs in broad daylight
on a residential street
the scandal isn't that you can buy these
lethal drugs on almost any street corner
of any city the scandal is that so many
vulnerable people are dying and nobody
seems to care if this was any other
section of society well there'd be opera
more people die from opioid abuse in the
uk than anywhere else in europe
and this number has been rising for a
decade i've been using cracks since i
was 16 but now like i'm mentally really
i've never been mentally ready to stop
using before and now i actually am
charlotte almost became a statistic
herself i went into the tent
to do my hit
and then all i remember is coming around
like
on the grass lid on the grass so i
literally od straight away but i was
lucky that the ambulance was there and i
just remember like coming around
big brother and shut up and you've been
addicted to heroin for 10 years have you
ever known anything like this before
no
no do you think anyone cares that people
are dying from heroin overdoses
um
right there's without fentanyl being in
it there's still a lot of heroin users
that die from overdoses
um
the issue becomes when
where there's more
people dying in a smaller space of time
nobody cares at all the other people
that care and i find that the people
that work in the dip teams that are
trying to get us on the script and
trying to help us live a normal life and
get onto the road of recovery
that must bother you that nobody cares
of course it does
of course it does i have a song for
myself you be 41-10
because i'm
i'm um
consistently a reminder of a world that
doesn't care
you're just a number on the list
yeah
drug services have seen their budgets
cut by around a third
since 2013
leaving those attempting to provide
support with fewer tools to help a
vulnerable community
that's growing older and weaker
over the past 10 years drug and alcohol
services have received significantly
less funding
and have become less easy to access and
certainly um
a bit more basic so people get less
support even if they can get a basic
level of treatment and
and as we know the treatment is
protective against overdose so if an
opiate user is in treatment they're
taking an opiate substitute so methadone
or buprenorphine then they are less
likely to overdose does anyone care
about heroin addicts dying
i think that's one of the problems i
don't think
generally speaking the population do i
think
[Music]
many people and perhaps it's reflected
in the government
don't care much
and that's why they've allowed
a treatment system to largely atrophy
some people care
there are good reasons to care
heroin users spend a lot of time in
hospital they cost us a lot of money
some of them commit crime
um and those are all good reasons why
supporting them properly
getting them into high quality treatment
probably in the end would save society
money
and it might be the humane thing and
it's very much the humane thing to do
yeah
in the northwest alone drug related
deaths are up by 77
in the past decade
here in wigan former addicts are working
with rough sleepers and anyone else who
might come into contact with vulnerable
communities about the signs of an
overdose
they also have a new weapon to cut
deaths
nalaxone
straight into the leg at a 90 degree
angle
into a muscle it goes in
and pressed down to line one
take it out
first responders including the police
are now carrying kits like these to help
save lives
oh you
it's not a cure but it does buy vital
time
until medical support arrives it seems
if i get everything and quicker if i'll
get everyone in wigan than it is forget
the taxi and wiggin that's
john was addicted to heroin
for over 20 years
now he works with people living his
former life
in the hope that he can make a
difference you were an addict or you say
you're still an addict yeah i've always
been had it 27 years not too fusiful
yeah 16 months clean the last mill after
my life now though i get up in morning i
do what i want not what dogs want me to
do
do you know what like when i was on
everything that i wasn't getting showing
stuff for and people think it's because
i don't want getting shower it's not
because i don't want to do edwin doesn't
want me to do i wake up i'll go on score
i'll get back and laugh what i'm doing
and then
just go back and score again have you
ever known it
this bad you've been a user for 27 years
you've known so many people to have died
from heroin no
no
i could give you good big lists of names
if i wrote them down
everybody knows dad feel
not so many still going now i'm lucky
for me alive
after all a lot of drug abuse
i suppose somebody's looking down them
in the line there
so i can do good work a day
why do you think heroin uses on the rice
because they're meant to off
and all services have been no services
over
way away for you that's yeah
um it's actually just [ __ ]
appointment mental health if you're
suicidal and that
people are shooting dogs from blackout
the stuff room again
it's an armor
morning and night or light and dark
whiskey brandy
water sweetness
yeah
the first step to addiction recovery is
admitting there is a problem
and the uk
has a growing opioid problem
until that's addressed people like bev
will continue to see their friends die
[Music]